Speaker 1: are becoming increasingly politically
relevant, as they are now regularly meant to
support 2022 candidates. Now, I was the first
to tell you last week Trump got two wins J.D.
Vance in Ohio, as well as what was the other one.
Now, J.R. Maju Ski in Michigan, who I interviewed,
I should remember him. Trump endorsed two people
and they won. But now we have a new challenge,
which is Dr. Mehmet Oz, who is running for the
Senate in Pennsylvania. Trump has endorsed him.
A lot of Republicans don't like
Oz. And the most notable thing,
the most notable thing about Trump's rally in
support of Dr. Oz over the weekend was not only
that the crowd sometimes booed Dr. Oz, but that
Trump seemed visibly disoriented and his speech
was extremely confused. Now we've gotten used to
the glitches from Trump, like you might remember
when Trump got his own name wrong at a rally.
Speaker 4: Anyway,
Donald Trump. Yeah. Donald Trump.
Speaker 1: When Trump got Obama's
name wrong at a rally.
Speaker 2: Obama.
Speaker 1: Went when Trump got the
name of Mexico wrong at a rally.
Speaker 4: In Mexico.
Speaker 1: And when Trump
got Mitt Romney's name wrong at a rally.
Speaker 4: A rhino named Mitt Romney.
Speaker 1: When Trump got the name of
someone he endorsed. Long at a rally.
Speaker 4: We've endorsed JP. Like JD Mendell.
Speaker 1: When Trump got the name of his own
social media platform wrong at a rally.
Speaker 4: Trump sent.
Speaker 1: Okay, so. But here, Trump
actually seemed confused about ideas.
For example, in this first clip, Trump says,
Pennsylvania is where our founding fathers
declared American energy independence. What?
Speaker 4: Pennsylvania is the commonwealth
where our founding fathers declared American
energy independence. Think of that. You're
the first ones. Many, many, many years ago.
Speaker 1: I don't know what he's talking
about. Maybe he just means
that Philadelphia is where
independence was declared. But energy
independence is not making a lot of sense.
Visibly disoriented, seemed almost punch drunk.
Then at another moment, Trump says that if Dr.
Oz wins, his wife will be the first lady of
Pennsylvania. But Oz's Oz is running for Senate,
not for governor. I could have has.
Speaker 4: I could have had a great out.
I could have had. And by the way, your wife is so
great, but you're going to get a great first lady
in the Commonwealth of Pennsylvania getting what?
First lady? I know her well. She's incredible.
And does she love her family,
her husband and her family? Yeah.
Speaker 1: So anyway, Aussies running for
Senate not I guess if it was the governorship,
you might say the first lady of Pennsylvania,
but all very strange. At another point,
Trump seeming to be kind of impressed in some way
that maybe Oz's TV show gets him girls. I mean,
this is just strange stuff on him a long time.
Speaker 4: His show is great. He's in that.
He's on that screen. He's in the bedrooms
of all those women telling them good and
bad and they love him. He came into a place
where we had a lot of women sitting there
waiting for something unrelated. They started
going crazy. Is that Dr. Oz? That's Dr. Oz.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So Trump seemingly jealous,
I guess, of the effect that Oz's show has
on women. Now, in all seriousness, the
entire rally was supposed to be for Oz,
and there was actually quite a bit of booing
whenever his name would come up. It doesn't seem
the Trump crowd is necessarily sold on Oz.
Speaker 4: My friend Dr. Mehmet Oz. He's a
great man.
Speaker 1:
And even a bunch of people interviewed before the
rally said, I am not sold on odds here. Trump did
an impression of a rocket ship. At one point.
Speaker 4: We endorsed JD and he was like
a rocket ship. He was going by yelling.
Speaker 1: And then at another point, he came very
close to calling Mitch McConnell a post, which I
love, quite frankly. I think the more that these
people can fight among themselves, the better.
Speaker 4: Mitch McConnell is the least popular
politician in the country, according
to them. I know he's an old broken down
crow. I want to be nice. I don't want
to go. Oh, I wanted to. I had that word
right. That I just want that I couldn't do.
I'd go home and the first lady would say,
Why did you use that foul language, darling,
I love you so much, but why did you use it?
Is it all broken down? Piece of crow. Yeah.
Speaker 1: A piece of crow and then just
some surreal Kafkaesque moments. And at
one point, a speaker brought up by Trump
referred to him as J.A. Donald Trump.
Speaker 5: President Donald J. Trump. To
thank for that, he gave me three shout outs.
I spoken to the rallies. I led the pledge.
Speaker 1: It was really quite a cast
of characters. When Mehmet Oz spoke,
it was pouring. He was soaking wet and he
talked about keeping the borders clean,
which I don't even know what that means.
Speaker 4: Face it, we'll fight back. You
want to fight China? China. Fight for it. Kids
in our schools, are you going to fight back to
keep our borders clean? You going to fight back?
Speaker 1: Yeah. You got to keep those borders
clean. Maybe with, like, an injection almost
of bleach or something like that. And then
maybe the most surreal moment Dinesh D'Souza
spoke, he has like a new I can't even call it a
documentary because it's all B.S. He has a new.
He has a new series of stitched together audio
visual bits, I guess is what we can call it. And
he has developed the term ballot trafficking.
It's not a term I've heard before. He may be using
the same random word generator that Trump uses,
but here he is. Listen to this.
Speaker 6: And paid ballot trafficking.
In some states, it is legal to give someone else
your ballot and have them drop it off. Usually the
conditions of that are kind of specified the
clear. In Georgia, for example, you can give
you a ballot to a family member or if you're in a
confined facility, you can give it to a caregiver.
Speaker 1: And as you can see, just an incredibly
riveting speaker. The people on stage right behind
Dinesh talking among themselves, many
of them not even facing Dinesh. Very,
very strange stuff. And lastly, it's not
a Trump rally until Trump literally leaves
you stranded in the mud. Here is video of
with Y.M.C.A. playing. Listen to this. And
leaving in the mud, trying to get around barriers.
It's completely flooded. Trump got the hell out of
there. And it is a classic at these rallies.
Horrible conditions, people getting stuck
sometimes for hours and just really a display
of the absolute worst, worst, worst of American
culture and politics. So the question will be,
does Oz win the primary with Trump's endorsement?
Because this one doesn't seem to be going quite as
well as some of the others. We'll have these clips
on our Instagram. Make sure you're
following us there at David Pakman Show